welcome to the NewsHour we begin with
the political turmoil in Niger it's been
one month since the military detained
president Muhammad bazoom and overthrew
the democratically elected government
the coup leaders have defied growing
International pressure to release him
and return the country to civilian rule
the hunter is rallying supporters to
what they describe as eight Million Man
March in the capital now it comes a day
after hundreds of people had a protest
outside the French army base there and
they want french forces to leave in one
week relations with the former colonial
power France are getting worse by the
day the military rulers have ordered the
ambassador to lead by Sunday after he
refused to meet with the foreign
minister and the West African Bloc
ecowas is increasing pressure on the
coup lead as it says it's determined to
end a spiral of coups in the region and
that military intervention is still very
much on the table well for the very
latest let's join emmed Idris who joins
us live from the capital Naomi with the
latest developments and we are expecting
a very busy day on this streets behind
you what are we expecting to happen
well we're expecting hundreds of
thousands on the streets and we've seen
some buses ferrying uh potential
demonstrators who will be there in a few
hours time we expect to see large crowds
and then we'll terminate at the National
Stadium here in the capital they are
expected to Rally to show support to the
government after a one month in office
the government obviously said in the
introduction remains defiant although we
understand that negotiations or
mediation is continuing but to how how
far will that go we don't and we don't
know at the moment but we understand
that a delegation from Nigeria after uh
directives from the Nigerian president
who is Chairman of the economic
community of West African States ask
them to continue with the dialogue and
that they will try as much as possible
to ensure that dialogue Works instead of
military action so what we expect to see
is today today what we expect to see
today is more rallies more rhetoric
ramping up especially in the face of of
the suspension or the expulsion of the
French Ambassador here and of course
more anger towards Echoes and all those
parties they say are promoting war in
the country instead of peace and then
let's just focus in on the French
Ambassador and the tensions that now
increasing between Paris and Naomi
regarding his position and what the real
problem is as to why he will or won't
meet the foreign minister
well I think at the moment relations
between France and Niger have been
damaged how far will that go and how
long will it take to sort of reconstruct
the relationship it's difficult to say
at the moment in fact yesterday there
was total confusion after uh
statements uh credited to the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs also announced the
suspension and expansion of diplomats
from Nigeria from Germany from the
United States which eventually the
ministry put out a statement to deny
that but again what we're saying is
really really a big a big problem for
France in this country there is
anti-french sentiment in this country
and of course there are concerns and
fears that this could spread from
diplomatic to now economic we know there
are several French interests in this
country mining in particular while
France mines uranium in the north of the
country and we're not sure at the moment
how far this will affect uh business for
the French and of course the
so we expect to see more in terms of
diplomatic and economic exchanges in the
coming weeks whether or not the European
Union will take sides is difficult to
say at the moment sale thank you for us
our correspondent thank you
let's join the Maori Roger below is she
is the president of the Africa
International Media Group joins me now
live via sky from the cameroonian
Capital One Day good to have you with us
uh Miss Roger below uh on Al Jazeera how
serious could the departure of the
French Ambassador be to this situation
and that political relationship between
Niger and France
I think the um
the situation quite a little bit
different from Mali and Burkina Paso
where the also there the ambassador of
the French Ambassador has been expect uh
this time around the the France is not
alone is not recognizing this military
gender and their position is they are
very consistent with theirs because the
the ambassadors who's supposed to be
expect has been summoned to a meeting
with the mirror gender and he refused to
go and that one the first reason the
military Junta gives for his expression
um and
prior to that
the the military Junta had announced
that now they are breaking up the
military
um agreements with France and France had
also said you are not entitled you are
not legitimate to do so so they rejected
that so the second thing they try to do
with this France
if I just jump in there ma'am while
these issues continue and fester if
there is a departure of the Ambassador
from Niger what sort of impact is this
going to have on the relationship really
with EU and Niger France is a major
partner in the EU organization it's hard
to imagine that the EU won't react to a
member State being told to leave near me
or are in your opinion those views
divided as well between EU member states
okay yeah
um
when the French Ambassador works well
for Mali and Burkina Faso not really
much happened I mean well they they wear
some retaliation like uh uh some uh
cooperation programs were suspended but
that's classical uh but this time the
story is not written yet uh let's see if
the French Ambassador really leaves uh
because France today feels what is
happening now in Niger has not much to
do with France
um that's the way they feel about it uh
maybe they fail to see that there's a
larger bigger picture where people are
fed up with front and Etc but on the on
on this particular particular moment
they feel there are many things
happening in the background like for
instance uh you know the president
bazzoon the the
democratically elected president who has
been overthrown maybe in the background
there's uh with his former uh with the
former president who handed over power
to him Democratic but stayed very much
in the background there was a feud on
who who will manage oil you know the new
or the new found oil and these things
like that so France is like let's wait
and see and the process of negotiation
is officially still going on as we know
so uh I think they want but now are they
wait to see what happens okay well the
chair is digging its heels in in that
it's given its authority to its Regional
neighbors to defend them if attacked by
foreign powers Niger seems certain the
writing is on the wall when it comes to
conflict is it
so I'm not sure I got you Niger is
digging its heels in it
Niger is digging its heels in it thinks
it's going to be attacked uh by ecowas
for example do you think the writing do
you think the writing is on the wall
well you know the what we know for sure
is that ecowas is determined not to let
go this cool this time around that's for
sure but now now they also see that the
the military option is very very
unpopular among Africans as a whole in
West Africa to begin with and uh on the
continent so they will they are figuring
out how they can deal with that but we
just know that uh the story is not
written yet we will see what happens
although uh some mediators say that the
military gender is totally in previous
to dialogue they don't want to hear
anything so I mean uh I think everybody
is now in the ecowas offices in in the
diplomats uh trying to figure out what
to do how to deal with those people we
should see what happens for the moment
Murray Roger below thanks so much for
joining us on Al Jazeera from Uganda
thank you